Now, I hope you have been saving words
and learning these words, or at least
reviewing them. Don't worry if you
remember them, you're gonna forget them.
But now you should try to save phrases,
because very often the individual words
don't give you a good sense of what the
words mean together in a phrase. If you
save the phrase, you'll hear the
text-to-speech, you'll get a translation,
which may or may not always be accurate,
but I find mostly it is, and then you
want to review these phrases, because
phrases have the advantage that that
they help you prepare to speak, because
when you go to speak you want to use
words that kind of belong together, that
are normally used together. So you should
get used to these. Direct your attention
to these phrases by saving them. You will
notice that other users have saved
phrases, and you'll see these sort of
outlined for you, suggested as example
phrases that you could save. Where
possible, save phrases and review them.
It'll be a big boost to your language
learning. Good luck!